so the only people who actually use
Groupons are old so I'm checking in with
some senior citizens to see what they
were group bonding in 2000 did you seem
like about a year and a half it's almost
like trendy again like you're kind of
like a hipster exactly you're bringing
it back because it definitely isn't cool
right now no so Allison back in 2012 you
got yourself a 16 minute Swedish massage
from bodice spa like what could have
been stressing you out so much in 2012
like what did you crack your iphone for
yes screen my wife's birthday was coming
up and so we went to what was called
pirate's dinner adventure but here's the
fact this was vampiress so basically
that means replace like rum like
yo-ho-ho right
so your first Groupon expired in 2011 I
mean back then Barack Obama was on his
first term who is running for he wasn't
even running for re-election this is a
different this is like dinosaurs were
walking the earth just like tell me when
to stop when I get to the right place
you got a Groupon for Quiznos I feel
like that's kind of ridiculous this is
2011
I was still in college I couldn't even
drink back then and you were Groupon in
Quiznos you saved you saved six dollars
oh cool listen I was a broke college
student then and I wouldn't even buy a
six dollar Quiznos Groupon this is
ridiculous thing the point of Groupon is
so you buy more things and then they'll
expire and then the places gets the
money without having to give you a
freezer just walk in with your game face
and be like I'm getting this couples
massage sometimes I would buy one and I
wouldn't actually use it
like what am I doing here that's hold
wasteful spending and it's something
that Republicans and Democrats agree we
should cut back on well
I agreed to that's why I stopped using
it